i can finally title my video anything i
want i have unhitched my wagon from all
star good morning hank it's monday do i
have a mustache
not only is it monday it's also pizzamas
everything's coming up green except for
this mustache of course which is
it's pizzamas a magical e-commerce
holiday where for two weeks hank and i
make videos back and forth every weekday
like it was 2007 all over again and we
saw lots of stuff with my mustachioed
face on it a reference to something from
2008 that i myself don't even remember
let's just go with it all the pizzama
stuff is available only during this
pizza mission all of our profits and
royalties go to charity to support
efforts to reduce child and maternal
mortality in impoverished communities
and in the case of a couple things also
to support international covid relief
efforts okay now i get to do an unboxing
first off we have circles pizza john
which brings together two of my favorite
things drawing tiny circles and
having a mustache then we have this work
of melancholic majesty in which i appear
to be crying a tear made out of pizza
oh my i love it so much it's it's my
it's my party
and i have a party hat i mean nature
finds a way
to create pizza johns i guess in
celebration of me going out into nature
more
they made a shirt where i turn into
nature
the seasons are changing there's never
been a better time for your pizza
john pullover hoodie that says pizza on
the sleeve
oh it's very comfortable by the way can
we talk about my mustache for a second
it's real bad
i mean this is just catastrophic maybe
it'll be better if i smile like
nope nope nope that's uh that's that's
that's worse oh i love this so much it's
strange and
beautiful just like pizzamas itself oh
my god every time i see my mustache in
the viewfinder it's ju
it's blinding oh look at this it's a
pizza john tote bag from pizza john's
pizza parlor in winter south dakota
oh no
it's
it's three me's howling at one moon it's
three
three john moon oh god i can't wait to
go on tour again hank so i can meet
people wearing this shirt
look at this it's a fancy cool tie-dye
pizza john i think i'm gonna put this
one on
oh i like that quite a lot oh boy
for all your christmas wrapping needs
there's some pizza john wrapping paper
so here's the deal if you buy all the
t-shirts you get a discount and then if
you buy
all of this year's pizza in this stuff
you get an even bigger
discount and then you can wrap it up in
your pizza john wrapping paper and give
it to a friend and they'll be so happy
and they'll have t-shirts and a hoodie
and lots of other things to get them
through
what may be a difficult winter we have
some very attractive pizza john crew
socks
then we've got our pins for this year
choose wisely because we've got a thin
crust pin and a deep dish pin
i'm a thin crust person so i'm going i'm
going with that
and it wouldn't be 20 20 if we didn't
have a pizza john mask
this is gonna be oh oh
oh yes oh my god oh i don't know what
else to say
i mean the great thing about wearing
this mask is that people will keep their
distance
we also have other great pizzamas stuff
including stickers and a fanny pack so
head over to pizzmus.com right now to
find it all it's only available for the
next two weeks and remember all our
proceeds go to charity hank happy
pizzamas
oh i will see you tomorrow
psync there's one thing you didn't
mention in your wonderful video about
our all-star project which is that it
was all
inspired by some youtube comments
especially one from maddie
five months ago in the comments section
to my video hey now matty wrote i want
hank to title his next video you're an
all-star
and go through the rest of allstar's
lyrics as video titles even if the
contents have nothing to do with the
title
seems like some vlogbrothers 2.0
nonsense and i'd be here for it
so to maddie and the other people who
made similar comments on that video five
months ago
thank you and also you never know when
you're gonna change the world with a
youtube comment
okay happy pizza miss pizzamus.com only
for the next two weeks
false sense of urgency